it's huge treat to have sundar pichai
CEO of Google here and you know I will
give a little bit of a preamble more
than I normally do and I think a lot of
the team knows this but it's always
worth reminding the team we wouldn't be
here on many levels if it wasn't for
Google clearly you know Khan Academy
certainly got a first attention on
YouTube I don't think I would have been
able to do what I did had YouTube not
existed when it did some of you all
might not realize but in 2005 we were on
Java servlet web hosting and that wasn't
scaling and so in January as okay
there's this thing called App Engine and
we went on there and and we have been
ever since so even from a platform point
of view but most importantly in the
early days when you know we were kind of
not even clear that we could even become
an organisation Google and Google org
was one of the very first to step up and
allow us to become a real organization
and ever since then through learn storm
and even existing grants are continuing
to support this so first of all just
thank you I'll offer a lot of people are
behind it I'm glad we're part of
something that's great so thank you
so so let's just start you know you've
well you're not new to the job as CEO
Google anymore it's been almost for two
years now a year haven't counted but
something like that so what's your view
of the you know of the world what you're
hoping to do at Google first of all
thanks for having me here you know I
have to confess there are times when I
have to speak at things like this and on
topics which I don't know much about I
may sneak into Khan Academy and see a
video here and there so I'm a user of
the platform as well you know from a
Google standpoint in some ways I think
we share a lot of you know what your
mission is as well our stated mission is
to bring information and knowledge you
know for everyone we take the for
everyone part seriously and you know we
we are we've been working on it for a
while but you know we again have this
renewed sense of excitement within the
company because of machine learning in a
we think over the next 10 years we can
you know take a bunch of stuff we've
been doing to a different level and you
know we are we are still in the early
days you know computers are just
beginning to kind of get better at
things like speech engine image
recognition that's what a lot of the
excitement is about when we say you know
we are making a lot of progress in
machine learning and so using that
thoughtfully across everything we do and
taking things to the next level is a big
part of our focus closely related to
that is you know building computing
platforms for everyone to I think you
know is personally very inspired by the
old PC project at the time you know
getting and I think that notion of being
able to make computing accessible to
everyone is very near and dear to a lot
of us particularly to me you know I
didn't have access to computing growing
up and you know I literally mainly got
it too at the end of my college and so I
have a very discrete sense of you know
the campaign you know how it how it
changed what I was able to understand
what I was able to get out of it so I
think we are in this part where it's
very exciting to see computing which you
know historically work for a small
percentage of the world now is you know
that penetration is getting better and
better you know mobile is that 3 billion
users now and I can see science we can
scale it beyond that so we are beat with
platforms like Chrome Android we've
always cared about making computing more
affordable and I'm reaching everyone I
think there are others working on
connectivity as well so the combination
of all that I think we can we can get to
a stage where pretty much sometime
within the next 10 years you know for
most people in the world I think you'll
be able to give them something which
with connectivity you know you have the
access of everything in your hands and
so I think that's a pretty profound
transformation and so you know broadly
that excites us and so and it serves
and well and be able to do well as a
company to mean wahoo haha you know as
we go through this so a lot of it is you
know actually viewing this advances in
machine learning and AI as an
opportunity to bring it in an equal way
to everyone and I think that that's
that's largely what excites me and it's
incredible I mean Google is one of the
few organizations in the world that are
in the position to do this but on top of
kind of all the I would say deep
technical work that y'all are doing
education I've heard is a big interest
area for you
Google has several initiatives in
education some of which we've been
interfacing with what's your view of
Google's role in education either
globally or in the u.s. I can culturally
we've always identified in a pretty deep
way with Academy or with education in
general and and so we see this as a big
area where you know I think you know as
I said our mission kind of you know you
know complementary to it and so we want
to play role to the extent we can we've
been fortunate in the sense that you
know our products have gotten very
popular in educational institutions all
the way from K through 12 largely with
Google Apps first and you know we have
done other things like classroom and
Chromebooks and so on we'll also do you
know not-for-profit initiatives in
education education as well so we are
investing more and I think when I when I
think about it I you know I think
education is obviously you know most of
you here understand better than me but
it's it's complex and you know we just
think technology can play in enabling
part you know it's talking with Sal
about this a bit but you know I think
when we look at immigrant when I look at
approaching many problems in the context
of Google we try to do things we try to
iterate now we see what works or doesn't
work and then you know we do these
things that way that concept is hard to
do in education rightfully so because
you know you don't want to get things
wrong but I think it's important to
figure out how to innovate more and in
that context I think technology can play
a part and so
to play a part and hopefully helping
people figure out what you know many
things to try when things work be able
to do more of it scale it more you know
how do you bring educators and children
all in a virtuous cycle together which
is what you all are working on so we you
know for me when I look at it it looks
like a complex ecosystem so we want to
see where we can enable these things and
so from from from a standpoint of
providing technology but a lot of people
are interested in Google beyond just the
products we build or the technology we
provide you know Google is a passionate
they want to volunteer a lot in
education for google.org it's one of the
important pillars on which we invest so
I think that's what makes makes it a
bigger thing for us yeah and you know
here kind of how you mentioned you
dabble a little bit you're just telling
me your daughter uses it yeah through
her school sometimes where do you see
ways that we can work together how we
can support each other's goals it's been
interesting to see which China from the
first time I saw Khan Academy to
actually you know my daughter you know I
see her sometimes come and she has
homework but it's part of like doing it
in Khan Academy I have to consider why
Lena or and make sure she is not just
using YouTube generally like that
outside of that small thing yep it's
pretty amazing to see that you know
teachers are using it and it's been it's
been great to see so you two are upset
when your children are hooked on YouTube
oh it's a sign that something's working
yeah no it's amazing the kind of stuff
you learn on YouTube I almost miss it
because they don't come to me with any
questions so like you know they they
kind of figured out they get their
answers from YouTube and later I'm like
oh you could have asked me maybe I would
have known the answer like you know in
terms of us working together you know I
do mean it when I say we think of our
role as enablers you know we participate
in many ecosystems and
in that way we approach it but I do
think there are areas where we care
about you know for you know when I
mentioned that for every one part I
think it's important we think one of the
things that attracted me to Google and
you know that Google search worked
globally right and you know it's kind of
like if you had access to computing and
connectivity and that's a big if but if
you had access to computing and
connectivity you actually really didn't
matter where you were accessing Google
from you kind of got the same thing and
that equality of access I think I think
is important so hopefully you know I'm
interested in you know our last round of
efforts you know we were excited about
your efforts to localize what you're
doing more broadly I think that's
important to us so getting these things
to work even in places like Brazil
Indonesia India and like how do you
scale it up I think is something we
deeply care about and direction we can
play a part in that we want to do that
you know the other part is I you know I
think given we are working on things
like not just our products classroom you
know detection via feedback on how we
can evolve what we do better you know
better to make all this work more
effectively for teachers and students
from for you all you know we are open to
trading our products that way you were
mentioning that you need is a plug in
the classroom and stuff that's you know
encouraging committee here and you know
we had also in early days of setting up
teams internally at Google to do other
things which are which I'm not going to
do with our products on education so
hopefully we can align better and make
some of them more complimentary yeah and
just a you know we importantly we could
talk for hours but this is kind of a you
know an ending question what advice you
know you've seen Google grow from a
relatively small stage to now it's this
thing that is you know actually
delivering on its mission and we have a
huge mission the free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and we
like to think we're already making a
dent in that but we were serious about
delivering what advice you have to us as
you know a relatively small team as we
try to go and try to do that over the
next five or ten years
you know I you're doing this party but
you know I wouldn't underestimate you
know the change you do at the tip of the
tree how fast it can slow down and you
know I think you know I think you've
already you know the fact that you guys
are approaching a space like education
and have shown that you can innovate in
the context of the space I think that
thing is a big thing you know we take it
for granted being in technology
companies like anytime we face a problem
we think we can break it we fail by the
way a lot but you know at least our
attitude is that you know you can
approach anything however complex it is
with an engineering mindset you know you
can try and understand how you know what
are the various components of it how you
can iterate and make things better it's
kind of the default assumption a lot of
us have but I think it doesn't always
translate to you know things like you
know many many outside things be
education or healthcare you know when I
deal with this I you know I realize well
we take this for granted and like that's
not how it works I don't mean in the
negative way there are good reasons why
those systems are the way they are and
you know you the cost of a mistake is
exceptionally high in something like
healthcare and so on but I think
figuring out how to you know innovate
you know it's just like I think an
imperative and and I think you know I
think hopefully you know you continue
pushing what you guys are doing already
and I think you've changed already the
conversation I'm amazed at where all
your name comes up and so you know
figuring out how to do that I think
because for every one thing you do there
is a multiplicative effect of how many
other people get excited by it so you
know 100 people organization here
effectively over time you're motivating
thousands and tens and thousands of
people to change their approaches and so
on I think I've always been you know the
the leveraged effect on top of a
platform is always very counterintuitive
to see like I can give thousands of
examples for the fact that everybody
starts using phones and phones have GPS
and location on them you know you assume
that it would change transportation one
day
but you kind of then like see you know
right sharing takeoff and things happen
like you know none of the people who are
working on phones ever had any remote a
sense that like people would use phones
and hence because of that how you get
the car changes right and so anything
you do at a platform level Happy's
nonlinear effects you know
extraordinarily leveraged ways to change
things and you know had a lot of
experience with this personally early on
when we were working on the web you know
few people working on browsers made
changes in the platform's so that you
can a synchronously you know what what
is later called as Ajax so that for
example if you are doing email just
because you want to change something in
the email or what you're seeing you
didn't have to reload the entire page
right and that small change left to
things like Google Maps you can scroll
you know you can drag and look at maps
and you know how maybe YouTube works and
how literally everything became
interactive on the web so anytime I
think you work at a platform level like
you end up impacting a lot more over
time than you think so I think trying to
platform eyes what you do you know so
that you know others can take it use it
over time rethink it you know I think is
very very powerful so hopefully you know
hopefully that's the way you impact a
lot of how education works as well also
well thank you so much for due today and
let's do this again all right thank you
guys
[Applause]